a huixtla en el sur de méxico dónde nos
encontramos ahora llegó la caravana de
miles de migrantes en su mayoría de
venezolanos para resolver por medio de
la presión simbólica de la marcha su
estatus migratorio los migrantes no
tienen otra cosa que este documento que
tanto les han negado la forma múltiple
de migración con la cual puedan
atravesar méxico rumbo hacia eeuu para
nosotros sentimos que méxico es más
difícil que pasar por el tapón del
darién o sea porque te digo aro ya
cuando llega a méxico llega sin dinero
los alquileres caros no te hacen el
proceso acumular la gente migración te
quiere sacar los hoteles de la casa
donde puede ver una persecución
almirante los migrantes viajan solos en
familia en estado de embarazo o con
bebés los que no son centroamericanos
tuvieron que atravesar la penosa selva
del darién y muchos trajeron
enfermedades consigo por lo regular en
los niños este se ve muy afectado por
igual los casos de insolación que ellos
llevan o presentan aún más que nada
luego de dormir a la intemperie y en el
piso como podemos ver en esta carpa los
miles de inmigrantes de la cara que
recorre el sur de méxico llegan a estas
oficinas de aduana en huixtla en donde
entregan sus pasaportes aspirando
obtener un permiso de 30 días para
moverse por el país deben armarse de
paciencia porque el proceso es lento y
solo cada hora entregan 20 pasaportes
firmados y solo esperamos que el
gobierno cumpla lo que estaba lo que
está prometiendo pero porque nosotros
también hemos cumplido de la forma de
escándalo de las formas
pelea riña ni nada porque la marcha es
pacíficamente pues la caravana según sus
organizadores comenzó con más de 15.000
migrantes pero hoy está fragmentada
muchos de ellos ya recibieron el permiso
migratorio para transitar por méxico y
no planean caminar más debido a la
penuria para sus pies en cambio tomarán
buses que los lleven a la frontera sur
de los eeuu para a través de acuña y
piedras negras atravesar el río grave